je vous propose de terminer ce journal
avec des images de fiction je veux dire
de cinéma je vais vous parler d'isabelle
adjani vous l'avez peut-être vu il ya
soir sur nos écrans de tf1 dans la gifle
avec lino ventura c'était son premier
grand film isabelle adjani avait disparu
pendant quelques temps des écrans elle
revient en force avec une présentation
remarquée au festival de cannes quartet
un film de l'anglais james ivory
vous verrez ce film dès cette semaine
d'ailleurs sur vos écrans mais en
exclusivité voici un extrait de ce film
c'est l'histoire d'une jeune fille
partagé entre deux amours après cet
extrait vous écouterez ensuite isabelle
adjani interviewé par michel loquet
voilà c'est fait
sensible aux japonais
d'ici peu
granby
qu'est ce qui vous a intéressé dans ce
sujet d'abord c'était c'est un rôle
c'était le rôle de jean with kids une
écrivaine moment que je trouve
formidable qui a écrit beaucoup de
romans sur la vie de l'école de l'époque
qu'on connaît très peu et qui était une
fille très courageuse a un petit peu
amoral qui vivait d'une façon très
moderne un peu contesté et qu'il a
raconté dans tous ses romans et moi ça
m'intéresse aide évidemment de jouer un
personnage pareil qui demandait à la
fois beaucoup dont certaines audaces 20
ans beaucoup de douceur parce que c'est
une fille qui a l'air soumises dans ce
film mais qui ce qui a pourtant la
volonté de savoir ce qu'elle fait même
si ce qu'elle fait c'est se perdre
il avait parlé un petit peu de votre
façon de vivre quand on essaie de vos
joueurs vous de vous contacter dans le
métier
non du tout chose tu sais je sais pas où
elle habite en ce moment oui c'est vrai
que ne pouvons pas transporter mon
appartement
le tract est comme une caravane gens
changent
et oui je me retrouve parfaitement bien
le jeu j'ai pas une nature à être
installée
je trouve que les films sont des
aventures qui dure c'est vrai deux mois
trois mois et parfois six mois avec les
préparations ou définition et que donc
ça mange une année que ça ex à manger
que ça empiète sur et vie privée puis
toute façon pour moi la vie privée et
privé c'est une chose dont qui existent
mais qui est totalement inséré dans le
travail et je trouve que ce sont comme
des vases communicants la vie privée
rentrer dans le travail le travail
rendant la vie privée isabelle a pris
possession et après le film d'ivory vous
avez dans un film qui l'opposait qu'il
une comédie car il faut peut-être
pressez vous aimez rire aussi
il n'a pas vu plus souvent vu au cinéma
c'est que le sujet s'y prêtait pas vous
aimez les comédies vous aimez ah oui moi
j'adore ça mais j'ai adoré faire la
gifle j'avais pourquoi venez aussi faire
via l'été françois et puis là cette
année je crois que je vais également bon
non pas que je crois je sais que je vais
faire un film sur paul rappeneau fin
juin donc avec yves montand et alain
souchon et puis donc le film de jean
loup hubert est une espèce de paris
parce que quand j'ai reçu le script
j'étais tout seul chez moi je me
souviens je me suis assise par terre
j'ai commencé à lire je suis dit wow qui
sait et puis j'étais écroulé de rire
pendant deux heures à la lecture ce
tellement du scénario tellement c'était
bien construit tellement les choses été
accéléré je voyais le film vraiment
défilé devant moi je me suis tellement
rare fos lancée même si là il n'a jamais
fait de film même s'il a jamais été
assistant même si rien on se débrouille
français alors le film de l'obrc l'année
prochaine si tout va bien si ça au mois
d'août serment douche avec le recul
vous mesurer le chemin parcouru et
spectaculaire devenir une vedette du
jour au lendemain statut de vedette est
tout de même un statut très arbitraire
et on sait pas où il commence on sait
par wi fi ni et c'est difficile de jouer
je sens aussi prendre